this is an example of a suspension
bridge and this
is a cable state bridge and an arch
bridge a beam bridge
there are a lot of different kinds of
bridges but they all serve the same
function
so bridge is a structure that's designed
to be able to carry
movable loads from one side to another
it needs to be able to traverse or span
a distance whether it's caused by a body
of water
or another road that's beneath it this
is the guy who decides what kind of
bridges to make
my name is dr nehemiah mabry i am a
structural engineer
and educator and what is a structural
engineer
structural engineer is an engineer that
specializes in designing structures
or any types of stable bodies that's
able to resist
lows or weights of any kind so why are
there so many different types of bridges
bridges are designed from the top down
but they're built from the ground up and
so we as engineers begin to think
how much load or what type of weight
does this bridge need to carry
and how would this deck then transfer
that weight
whether it's a moving truck or a resting
parapet or concrete divider how do you
decide what kind of bridge to build
right so there's a couple of things we
look at when we want to design a bridge
so you look at skew angle you're going
to look at
stationary or work points you're also
going to look at what we call a typical
section
which is what is it going to look like
if once we slice this bridge in half
what do we want that typical section to
look like and then from there
once we get that it's a matter of
calculating the loads
that the various lengths of girders or
various length of materials that are
necessary
we're going to also look at the material
that we want to use to then be able to
produce that typical section that we
desire there are primarily two main
forces
that each component each member of a
bridge is going to experience
is either a tension force or a
compression force a tension force is
basically a force
that will attempt to try and stretch the
member or stretch
the component of the bridge and a
compression force
is a force that will attempt to shrink
the member or
the component of the bridge and so those
are the two main forces
that any member of the bridge will have
to experience
some members will have to experience
both at the same time for instance
if you have a beam now a beam is a long
member that is meant to span from one
support to the other support
in many typical cases the beams are
supporting
the loads transferred from the deck well
in the middle of the span these beams
are often
bending or experiencing stresses or
a force that causes a bend well in this
case
you're going to have the bottom of the
beam that's going to be tempted to be
stretched that is a tension force
however the top of the beam as it bends
is going to be experiencing a
compression force because at the top
it's going to be shrinking an example of
a component experiencing maybe just
compression
would be the columns this is a member a
part of the substructure which is
connected directly to the foundation
as lows from the beam rest on the
columns
the columns are going to be experiencing
compression more specifically
axial compression along the length of
the column another case where
tension may be the only thing given a
case of a
suspension bridge these are bridges
where you see a draping cord or cable
going from one support to the other and
then hanging from those draping cables
are additional cables that are then
attached to the deck to hold up the deck
well these particular cables are
experiencing pure tension
because it is experiencing a force that
is stretching those cables
so here's a bunch of different bridge
types suspension bridges
they are typically supports or towers
connected by
a draping cable and from those draping
cables on both sides of the bridge
there are vertical cables that then
connect to that draping cable
down to the deck and the weight of the
deck is then resisted by those vertical
cables and tension
connected to the draping cables that
then transfer the load to these
towers what's the best example of a
suspension bridge
the most recognizable example
particularly in the united states
is the golden gate bridge the golden
gate bridge is that bright red that
beautiful
landmark out west that has these two
very strong draping cables going from
the north
to the south tower and from those cables
they're typically made of
steel wires wound and compacted together
which make them very very very strong
and tented draping vertically from those
main cables down to the deck
what's so great about this suspension
bridge is that it's in a region that is
known to experience
earthquake being that they are supported
by cables
for the most part there is the ability
for
bridges like this to be able to have
some sort of give
and not be so stiff and be able to move
even if the ground shakes without
severely damaging itself
the north and south ends of a suspension
bridge particularly
the golden gate bridge are referred to
as peers and these peers
act as the substructure which needs to
resist
those forces that is being applied to it
by these main cables
and so these big piers need to be
extremely reliable
because they are essentially resisting
half of the bridge's weight
[Music]
what's another type of bridge another
similar or cousin
i like to think of to the suspension
bridge is a cable state bridge
in this case they're similar in that
there are towers primary supports that
then connect to the ground
but instead of having two main draping
cables the cables are then attached
directly
from those towers from those piers to
the deck each side of the tower
sort of acts as a counterweight to the
other side and so this is not only
helpful in the way that
the bridge remains in equilibrium but
this is also something that
many have used to their advantage
throughout construction of those bridges
as well
by holding things in place as things are
being built
what it allows you to do is use cables
to then
act as a resisting force to the
suspended or hanging deck because the
deck in and of itself
is not required to have anything beneath
it your cables are able to go
much much longer than you could
fabricate anything else
to serve as a superstructure so cable
stayed would be really useful for long
or tall bridges
yes so the milan buy it up is actually
the tallest bridge in the world being
that you have each piers
that is about the height of the eiffel
tower itself and from it you have your
cables that are
keeping the deck in place making it a
very aesthetically appealing bridge but
also
using the counterweights of both sides
to be able to have a much
longer span in between piers than you
would with any other bridge type
it's only but so long you can design a
plank or a girder and so because you
don't want to have so many supports
also when you're traversing or you're
building a bridge across a large body of
water
the energy and the effort it takes to to
drill
piers or or piles down beneath the
surface
of the water and to build these supports
makes it more of an incentive
to have less supports right and because
we want less supports
we're then going to consider a bridge
type that can
allow us to have longer spans hence the
suspension bridges
and even more so the cable state bridges
becomes
an attractive option not to mention it
just looks cool
so that means some cable state bridges
might have only one support
right exactly so the langkawi sky bridge
is a curved pedestrian bridge
it's just beautiful it has the aesthetic
value right there it's an interesting
design challenge
when you look at how can we put this
man-made structure in this place
but yet at the same time preserve the
natural beauty
of that environment so it is then
advantageous to then say how can we have
the minimal amount of peers in this case
even one peer positioned and act as a
support
for the entire bridge which is why this
trust pier
is singularly located and then attached
to cables eight cables to be exact that
are necessary
to support the deck in various points
thus providing the
support needed to support the traffic
can you combine these different bridge
types
yes so the brooklyn bridge is a good
example of
a hybrid between a suspension bridge as
well as a cable state bridge
so you have your very very large towers
your pillars
your piers that have existed for a very
very long time
that have these draped cables from one
to the other
from these drip cables there are
vertical cables that are attached to the
deck as you would see in any other
suspension bridge but if you look very
very closely you will also see that some
cables
are at a diagonal they are also attached
from the deck directly to these tower
piers which makes it more of a hybrid
between
your suspension bridge as well as your
cable state grid the cables of the
brooklyn bridge
are comprised of 19 strands that are
then bundled together
and then each of these are composed of
about 278 wires
per strand and together they actually
produce a much
stronger tension resistance than if you
just had a single
solid strand those towers on the
brooklyn bridge are stone towers as well
using limestone granite and other rocks
that have proven to be able to stand the
test of time
because of their durability and strength
and compression
[Music]
what is our third bridge type arch
bridges
are primarily resisting the load in
axial compression along the arc
within arc bridges themselves you could
have a spandrel art bridge where the
deck is above the arch
or there are cases where the arch is
elevated and the deck is actually
through the arch
and so we call that a through arch
bridge particularly stone
bridges standard test of time because
stones are natural material
and so using the material that has
already went through the years of
weathering countless years of
reformation and
really been able to remain what it is
over
millennia so i think that's one of the
reasons why stone bridges
and even arch stone bridges is able to
stand the test of time because it's
simply asking of the material what the
material has already been doing
for many many many years when it's
designed appropriately
and the geometry is nailed you can
pretty much have a bridge that
is invincible what's a good example of
an ancient
arch that's still standing today so the
aqueduct is another example of a
stone arc bridge here we have series of
stone arcs that allow the force to be
transferred actually throughout the arc
these smaller arches then of course
transfer the load to the bigger arches
it takes advantage of the opportunity of
breaking up the spans
such that so much isn't required of a
single
arch it's also redistributing the load
along across the smaller arches
so that as they're transferred upon the
bigger arches
the larger arches can then act as piers
that are spaced further out apart giving
greater spans
[Music]
what then is a truss bridge a truss
is a structural type that is comprised
of
several different elements the
triangular shapes are
necessary such that each element of the
truss is
experiencing a pure tension or pure
compression
can you give us an example so the city
of harbor bridge employs
two trusts in the shape of an art and it
also
is the type of art that we refer to as a
through art bridge
such that the deck is not above the ark
but it's in line or belief the apex of
the art there are also vertical struts
that then connect from the truss arcs
that are to
support the deck through tension this
aligns with the use
of the elements within the truss as well
which are also designed and put in place
to be able to only experience purely
actual forces whether it be in
compression
or in tension aren't trust bridges used
by the military for rapid deployment
absolutely the bailly bridge is sort of
a military bridge that is
prefabricated pre-built away from the
site that it is to be put in place
to transfer vehicular or pedestrian
traffic it really came out of the need
for military units to be able to quickly
build a bridge
for it to be light enough for them to
carry with them as they move from one
place to the other and it's sort of like
an erector set
piece by piece pre-fabricated put
together
and can be constructed without the use
of heavy machinery
without the use of a crane or any pile
drivers of any sort
[Music]
what type of bridge is this so a
cantilever is a structure that is
supported on one end where there is a
fixed
side or support whether beams or
other types of support members that are
resisting the rotation
of the deck and so cantilever is
incredibly important to make sure that
the fixed end is strong enough
and that the flexing extended member has
the ability to resist the tension on the
top and the compression on the bottom
perhaps the longest cantilever bridge is
the ponte quebec bridge
there in quebec canada still unlike
concrete
is extremely strong and tension it can
resist
forces that attempt to stretch it and so
while we are making beams
that perhaps are going to experience a
lot of
bending we want something that can
resist
the compression at the top and the
tension at the bottom
or vice versa depending on how it's
expected to bend so how do you make a
material that resists heavy loads
we've gotten very sophisticated in how
we are anticipating
the types of loads that these beams are
going to experience
and so instead of just simply putting
steel inside of the concrete
so that you have that reinforced
composition there's another type that we
call pre-stress concrete we take the
steel
before we bring the concrete in and we
stretch out the steel
and while in that tension position we
then pour the concrete around it
and create a beam with the tension steel
and after that concrete has hardened
then we release the tension off of that
steel such that now
the steel wants to then retract back to
its original position
but because it now has concrete around
it it is actually
pre-stressing before it experiences any
load it's already applying a stress
load on the concrete and so now you have
a bowl
where the concrete or the beam is going
to want to naturally without any load on
it
bow up a little bit and so that's a way
to sort of anticipate
the fact that when lows go and we put
these beams in place the lows are going
to want to make the
the beam deflect downward but because we
put what we call
camber we put camber into this
pre-stress
beam we sometimes are able to achieve
no deflection at all at the beginning of
installation
[Music]
what other bridge types are there when
we're talking about plank bridges
then those planks are acting as beams
and so they have to resist
what we call bending moment and so a
bending moment
is what causes these beams in this case
to experience both tension
and compression compression being at the
top as it begins to bend
and tension being at the bottom as it
begins to deflect so the ubn bridge
is the largest wooden footbridge in the
world
it has upwards of a thousand wooden
pillars
that have been driven throughout the
water along the length of the bridge
it has approach bands that were
originally made of stone or brick but
had then also been replaced by wood
over time the weathering and the
deterioration of certain pillars have
been replaced with concrete
but nevertheless this is primarily an
entirely
constructed wood bridge that offers
amazing views there in miramar
along the length of this bridge there
are four wooden pavilions
at equal distance i don't know you're
calling maybe
checkpoints along the length of the
bridge being that it's so long
[Music]
so what about this bridge in inoshima
japan what type is this
this bridge is another pure example of a
bridge type there aren't
separate members that you're connecting
and transferring low with but it can
almost be looked at as a
frame in and of itself that put in place
and you look at it and that's the money
side
right there right looking at the super
steep incline and decline that
it has when you're approaching the
bridge that shot definitely it helps
exaggerate
the steepness of the gray however it is
a lot steeper than your typical bridge
on its
vertical curve as we call it it has
about five percent six percent
slope which is quite the slope for any
passenger or vehicle driver may
typically drive on but it's necessary
because
instead of being a movable bridge they
decided to make it high enough with
enough vertical clearance such that the
ships can
then pass there in japan right
underneath it without
any needs of actuators or mechanical
devices to be able to
to move it
[Music]
and then there are movable bridges
movable bridges
are things that we see that are designed
to be able to
not only transfer the load sturdily
continuously using a deck that connects
across
the chasm but it's also designed by some
mechanical
powered devices to be able to move and
to lift up
such that the waterway that is
traversing could allow the patches of
boats or
any other vessels that need to pass by
it can then also be lowered back in
place
so that the lows can continue to travel
across it let's hear an example
so the somerset bridge is a very very
short timber bridge
to be able to cover a passageway in
bermuda that connects
somerset to work bermuda and it's a
movable bridge as well
this bridge doesn't need to be
completely moved out of the way there
aren't big
ship or water vessels that are passing
through in fact
this movable bridge is operated by hand
unlike other movable bridges which may
use hydraulics or other mechanical means
it's just
hand crank bridges that allows the deck
to open up
just perhaps two or three feet just wide
enough for
a mask of a small boat to be able to
pass through
what about a bigger example okay yeah
okay i got you
gateshead millennial bridge this bridge
is actually a pedestrian bridge
not meant to to transfer any vehicle
traffic
but walkers joggers cyclists are able to
travel that curved
outer semi-circle of the bridge it's
amazing because it has sort of that
eye look it's referred to as the winking
eye
as a nickname just incredible and
incredible just
marvel particularly when it first went
up it was one of the first of its kinds
that we've ever seen like that instead
of actually moving and
separating two components of the bridge
it is shaped in a way such that the
semicircles
are able to rotate and when it is in the
upright position
it then creates enough vertical
clearance for ships and sea vessels to
then pass underneath
and then it's simply rotated back into
its place
what about this sci-fi looking bridge
the rolling bridge
it's pretty cool looks like a little
roly-poly bridge and what's interesting
about this bridge is that
as in a lot of movable bridges this has
several joints throughout
and triangular sections such that it's
able to curl up
upon itself with multiple bending
locations throughout the length of the
bridge so as it curls up
using the power of hydraulics being a
system that employs the pressure
of fluids it's able to then at its size
be deployed very quickly rolled up put
back down
again nice and neatly the triangular
segments fold on top of each other and
then roll back out just as easy as you
would see a roly poly do it
is there one bridge that puts a bunch of
these examples together the tower bridge
is another
kind of hybrid bridge it's a suspension
bridge
and then it's also a movable bridge in
the middle on the outsides
of the towers there are suspension
cables vertically supporting the deck
but then there is a walkway bridge at
the top of the two towers beneath there
is a drawbridge that
lifts up allowing the passage of ships
but what's interesting about the tower
bridge is that there is also a walkway
bridge at the top
which in and of itself acts as a
connecting member between the two towers
because the outsides of the towers are
suspension bridges
they are experiencing sort of a pulling
force
that's attempting to pull them apart
therefore
the walkway that is connected at the top
is acting as a
connecting member that's experiencing
tension itself keeping the top of the
towers also aligned and in place
[Music]
what is the same about all these
different bridges
all of these different types of bridges
are essentially doing the same thing
they're carrying low and they're
transferring it to the ground they're
just accomplishing it in slightly
different ways
so how do you make sure a bridge stays
up for a
very long time a lot of infrastructure
that has been built years ago
expiring for lack of a better word
around the same time
causes decision makers to have to
determine what will we replace
entirely and what can we afford to just
simply repair
it's not uncommon for bridges to be
designed with what we call a 50-year
design life cycle bridges incorporate
a lot of reliability measures
which determine with a high reliability
this bridge will be safe for this amount
of time say 50 years
that doesn't mean that this bridge can
no longer perform its function after
that design
life however this is just the highest
interval of confidence for which that
structure can be designed
you may see in our country particularly
in countries that had
large massive infrastructure projects 50
or so years ago
now at a point where a lot of our
heavily used bridges
and structures are requiring frequent
maintenance there needs to be a more
frequent inspection cycle there needs to
be
perhaps some modifications removal of
the concrete that has
spalled off or deteriorated or crumbled
and replaced with something more durable
such as
weather protector steel which we have or
epoxy coated deck
and so there are rehabilitation efforts
that can
just as well reduce or restore the
ability of the bridge
as opposed to just tearing it down
perhaps there may be cases where an
engineer may go and inspect
they analyze they look at how it may
have deteriorated
or fatigued over its life cycle and
they won't recommend that it be torn
down but they may recommend that it be
posted
and that instead of carrying a certain
amount of load now it be determined that
it can only carry
a fraction of that load and continue to
then function safely for the public
restoring urban infrastructure is a huge
issue because of the fact
that the uses increase at such a higher
rate and that's why
in new york a lot of the bridges the age
of the bridges as well as the levels of
use that they experience
require more frequent intervals of
repair maintenance
inspection for the public we have a high
number unacceptable number
of either structurally deficient or
functionally obsolete bridges
which is why there has been widespread
support for
the restoration and improvement of our
nation's infrastructure so the choice is
either
preservation and repair or completely
new construction